what it's my day off give her those days
off you're just like I'm not gonna do
jack [ __ ] today that was today nope
here we are cuz what the [ __ ]
happening with spider-man for those of
you who don't know it looks like a
storms possibility if not probability
that spider-man is out of the MCU
because of some dealings and contractual
[ __ ] or between Disney and Sony I
say possibility and probability rather
than certainty because in the words of
the great Kane from legacy of kain fates
promises more twists before this drama
unfolds I was actually gonna hold off on
doing a video about this feels like I
wanted more information than I realized
there's just there's always gonna be
more information tomorrow there's gonna
be more information the time between me
filming this and me uploading this rest
assured there are new developments to
know here we are on the ragged edge
whatever happened we all were yo
spider-man's going to the MCU we were
all jacked spider-man spider-man
look at that naive bastard he doesn't
even know he has no idea where this is
gonna go cuz he doesn't yet realize
whenever there's a contract there's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] involved somewhere
basically long story short I feel like
this happened yeah these are your
friends over here at the largest studio
in earth how you doing sir to you this
comes as a bit of a shock to us as well
but we think for the young room it's
best if we do something like this it
wouldn't sure our brand you know our
brand is very important the brand of the
brand and I feel that spider-man is now
a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
brand I mean as you say we didn't set
him up to be the new Tony Stark see you
face sorry I just I just have one thing
to head [ __ ] but I don't know I wasn't
there it's just what it seems like it
does feel like now looking back does it
take away from the purity of the
situation spider-man in the MCU and how
they've built him up you know building
him up this the next Tony Stark building
him up is this really important Avenger
now I feel like it's strong-arming a bit
you know because you have the contract
right that that's one element of an for
but really the court of public opinion
is powerful thank tinfoil hat moment
what if Disney Marvel Studios what if
they were like well we know that stone
is gonna take spider-man back but if we
build spider-man up to be so important
in the MCU what if they'll then feel
like they just can't take him back what
if that'll give us the leverage ah
I mean it's Hollywood I know that
somehow Twitter's normalized the
Hollywood mindset but at what [ __ ]
points is that mindset remotely normal
it's not they're crazy
Oh so after all that all that build-up
all that hey spider-man Peter Parker is
so important in the MCU I guess we're
just going on without it but all this
[ __ ] is why I kind of see the MCU okay
up through the Thanos thing up through
endgame I kind of see it like Breaking
Bad not saying it's the greatest
television drama of all time but what
I'm saying is you could see it as all
right you have your epic and it wrapped
up right and so now going forward phase
4 on we can see that as better call Saul
where it's like all right if it's
entertaining I'll be pleasantly
surprised but it doesn't have to be
because I still have my wrap up I still
have my epic that wrapped up and I'm
fine with that
I feel like this is a case of someone
who's just won so much I mean do Disney
the MCU they've been in the [ __ ] zone
it's like anyone anyone any studio it's
just it's human nature when you're in
the zone that much to be like I'm
invincible I'm untouchable who's gonna
say no to me oh [ __ ] that company just
said no to me and they threatened to
take their awesome character back this
really helps us out ah [ __ ] me I'm
stupid didn't Tom Hardy say that
spider-man in the venom movies is a
possibility did he know something did he
know about this stuff or maybe I'm
misremembering that I do feel like
someone said something about that I feel
like it might have been Tom Hardy well I
guess it's possible to have spider-man
in a venom movie now like who and he
didn't really have anything to do with
venom at all god these are the goings on
though this is what happens it's just
big studios pining for our attention in
any way possible
happy better get on tinder because
that's that's ending sorry happy we were
rooting for you I will say though I have
loved spider-man in the MCU Cinematic
Universe superhero movies and standalone
non cinematic universe superhero movies
that do fundamentally feel different the
part of
four words of a good stand alone
spider-man movie where he's spider-man
he's Peter Parker he's trying to balance
life he's trying to make ends meet and
pay rent so glass half full there is
that so hopefully Sony can take it all
in learn from the good spider-man movies
and the bad and do what they did with
the good spider-man movies oh really how
much did Marvel have to do with the
spider-man game that came out for the
Sony Playstation you just have all those
riders make a spider-man story for Sony
because that's the greatest spider-man
movie of all time is that game I mean
that hook at the end of spider-man far
from home does that matter
if they do another spider-man are they
going on that arc are they like dad we
got to recast another person we got to
do completely different movies or is it
able to essentially be MCU ish
spider-man are they able to carry his
arc throughout just without the MCU
people but I believe I heard somewhere
Tom Holland has a couple more movies on
his contract I don't know if they're
just general MCU movies that he'll pop
into or if they mean he has a couple
spider-man movies in the MCU no there
was no spider-man 3 on their face for
lineup there is also that don't believe
hippo can be like hi guys I'm moving
very far away plus the phase-out will
begin uh who knows like I said tomorrow
I imagine a hundred phone calls will
have happened now that there's all this
internet chatter especially and there
might just be new developments tomorrow
tomorrow everyone might be like hey it's
all good that was close in a world of
big studios and contracts it's this [ __ ]
was it's almost inevitable to happen
it's weird it hasn't happened before
this but it does show that no studio is
above someone or something else telling
them to go [ __ ] themselves now we'll
just we'll take it back then I hope
Disney feels it's mortality in this one
I really do because they need to feeling
your mortality it's it's what keeps you
humble it's what keeps you human is what
keeps you down here on earth with the
rest of us folks
I mean if Disney was like oh no dude
you're Thanos run is done and your fins
generally don't give a [ __ ] about Star
Wars anymore no you should probably keep
spider-man around I'm just saying it
could only help you anyhow this
[ __ ] what are your thoughts
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more coffee
is my [ __ ] hero
[Music]